الطفل البالغ من العمر 13 عامًا الذي
أصيب بصاروخ حوثي في المدينة اليمنية لا
ستطيع التنفس.  تنفس أحد أصدقائي كان
ميتًا
والآخر بدا وكأنه على
وشك الموت
في جناح آخر ، وأظهر نائب مدير المستشفى
لي صديقًا آمنًا وما هي حالته
تحت التخدير وهو يتشبث بالحياة
إنه في حالة سيئة
كيف الحال بالنسبة لك  كطبيب لرؤية
العديد من الأطفال المصابين يأتون من كل
هذه الصواريخ
بعد كل هذا الوقت. طبيب عيون من
خلال التدريب
، يقول إنه ليس لديه كلمات لوصف
المعاناة
ولا خيار سوى الاستمرار في محاولة المساعدة
والأمل في
أن ينتهي القتال
ولكن الهجمات على  تصاعدت أزمة مأرب بعد أن
بدأ الرئيس بايدن في الضغط على جميع الأطراف لإنهاء
الحرب
، وتتحمل الإدارة الأمريكية
مسؤولية كبيرة عن هذه الجريمة ،
حيث أزالت الحوثيين من
قائمة الإرهاب ، لكن ليس هناك ما هو أكبر.
إرهابي من الحوثيين
يجب أن يدعمونا مرة واحدة
، أصبحت واحة ماريب الصحراوية الأسطورية الآن
ملاذًا في زمن الحرب لأكثر من مليوني
شخص بوابة للكثير من ثروة اليمن من
الغاز والنفط
وهي آخر معقل رئيسي للحكومة المعترف بها دوليًا
في شمال اليمن
مأرب وهي مهمة للغاية بالنسبة لها.  تفقد
الحكومة نفوذها الحيوي في أي محادثات سلام مستقبلية ،
ما يحدث هنا الآن أمر
محوري لمستقبل البلاد
في مأرب ، حيث يعيش العديد من النازحين
داخليًا أو مخيمات النازحين داخليًا
في التوازن
الذي كان الثنائي البالغ من العمر تسع سنوات يتخلصان منها
تخبرنا الأم أن هجمات الحوثيين تجعل الفاعل
خائفًا للغاية
عندما نسمع سقوط الصواريخ بالقرب
منا جميعًا خائفين ، كما تقول ،
حول مخيمات الخيام بالمدينة ، تسببت مؤخرًا في
نزوح مسؤولي الإغاثة المتزايدين من
أن هجوم الحوثيين قد يجبر
الكثيرين هنا على الفرار مرة أخرى بالتأكيد
بسبب  لقد استمروا في التحرك الآن معظمنا
لدينا الكثير من idbs الذين
نزحوا للمرة الثانية والثالثة ،
والبعض منهم رابع مرة
لذلك  بالتأكيد سيكون هناك الكثير
من التحركات الأخرى للناس
، ثم إضافة إلى المعاناة
، تكشف رحلة عسكرية يمنية إلى خط الجبهة
مدى خطورة المدينة التي
يخبرنا بها الجنود في الشاحنة أن
هناك قتالًا هنا
كل يوم على مدار الأشهر القليلة الماضية.
السبب في أننا نقود
بسرعة كبيرة جدًا ، وذلك بسبب
الخطر والرجل الذي يقود عجلة القيادة
وهو رئيس أركان الجيش
في الطريق الذي يتوقف فيه يرحب بزعماء القبائل
الذين بدون مقاتليهم لا يمكنه الصمود في
الخطوط الأمامية
ويوقف آخر هذه المرة
يحاول كل من قواته هو ووزير الإعلام
رفع الروح المعنوية للجنود ، واعدًا
بأنهم سيحصلون على رواتبهم ، وهم يفعلون
ذلك في الجبهة نفسها ، ويتصاعد غبار ترابي صغير
من سيارات الحوثيين
ويبدأ إطلاق النار على
هذه السيارة للعدو
[موسيقى]
لقواته  يخسرون الأرض بعد ضرب
المرتفعات الجبلية الإستراتيجية
الحوثيون الأقرب إلى مأرب
حسنًا ،
نحن نتراجع عن خط
المواجهة شعر القائد أنه أصبح أمرًا
خطيرًا للغاية
أن تبادل  كان إطلاق النار يسخن
ولم يكن واضحًا له
كيف كان سيحدث ،
توقفنا بالقرب من بندقية متداعية
تمركز فيها
عتاد عسكري هنا قديم
متناثرة ونادرًا ما لا يمكن
تجاوزه
في عجلة من أمرهم يعتمدون عليه  بشأن
الضربات الجوية للتحالف السعودي
التي تسببت بالفعل في مقتل أكثر من 18
ألف ونصف مدني
يمني لإيقاف الحوثيين والشعور بالضعف بسبب
قرار بايدن إنهاء
الدعم العسكري الأمريكي لها
، قال متحدث باسم وزارة الخارجية إن
الرئيس بايدن جعل
إنهاء الحرب في اليمن  أولوية قصوى
مضيفًا أننا نواصل اتخاذ إجراءات
ضد أولئك الذين يهددون
أمن وسلامة اليمن واستقراره ، لكن
إضافة جهودنا وحدها لا تكفي ،
فنحن بحاجة إلى جهد دولي موحد
خاصة للضغط على الحوثيين لإنهاء
هجومهم على مأرب.